[Musique]
celle-là on l'attendait plus alors que
tout le monde avait la tête tournée vers
son réveillon dans les huîtres et le
foie gras
l'union européenne et la grande bretagne
nous ont sortis du chapeau un accord de
dernière minute comme ça à l'arraché
il faut dire qu'avec des économies déjà
bien entamée par la pandémie
les deux parties avaient plutôt intérêt
à se mettre d'accord alors finalement il
ya quoi dans cet accord
on va pas rentrer dans les détails on
préfère être honnête on va pas tout lu
c'est quand même un pager 2009 146 pages
mais dont dans les grandes lignes
l'accord garantit des échanges sans
droits de douane me cotta à un accès
pour les pêcheurs européens aux zones
britannique le respect mutuel de
conditions d'une concurrence équitable
une continuité pour les transports ou
encore le respect des programmes
européens par les britanniques et
d'autres petits alinéa en tous genres
finit par exemple la libre circulation
des britanniques et le droit de
travailler librement sur le territoire
européen sans s'y installer mais tout
sera arbitrée par une sorte de
commission mixte où va ce qui devra
veiller à ce que chaque parti tienne ses
engagements
bref tout le monde est content et il n'y
aura finalement pas de redouter no deal
qui était encore l'option la plus
probable quelques jours avant les fêtes
peut-être enfin l'épilogué d'un
feuilleton qui nous aura tenu en haleine
pendant quatre ans et demi
[Musique]